simon cowell we need you back get well
brother because i'm sure
simon would have plenty to say about the
agt contestant who took
aim at heidi clune the comedian
was not your was just not your flavor
was he to me
it was all not so funny the dj could say
anything he wants
heidi if i called you a [ __ ] you'd be
like how dare you right
but if i was like [ __ ] [ __ ]
trump [ __ ] you'd be like well i do get
loose on occasion
that look right there says it all i
don't know being called a [ __ ] probably
was my
least uncomfortable part of the whole
thing
it's hard to be a comedian now but i
don't know i just didn't love his
material so much today
comedian usama siddiqui's risque routine
was the most awkward moment of the night
this morning he tells me he stands by
the joke do you want to
send her a little love and maybe
apologize to her the joke i'm not
apologizing for i love the joke
all left to hidey last night agt did not
have a fill-in for simon
who broke his back 18 days ago will he
show up for the finale
i wouldn't put it beyond him that man is
is like a superhero you know his back
has been broken they put a rod
in his back i know that he's up and
walking and he's working miracles